he's going to be spending tons of money
i mean we we are busting the budget
in a way that is unimaginable we can't
pay for it
bills come due every dollar the
government spends is
one more like it's a deeper finger in
your pocket
that is squeezing you in places you
shouldn't be squeezed it all comes back
to bite us
and joe biden is out of control in that
sense
i want to bring up a completely
fictitious event because obviously this
didn't happen
uh but let's just say one of us had a
party a little bit after the election
and let's just say there were a bunch of
political people at this party and we
were sitting around a fire and let's
just say maybe there were a couple
joints being passed around
and let's just say some of the people
voted for trump and some of the people
voted
for biden this of course is completely
fictitious neither one of us good
decent citizens law abiding would ever
do something like this and let's just
say
some of the uh the biden people were
feeling good and the trump people were
kind of feeling upset and let's just say
you
and again this is completely fictitious
actually said to everybody
you know maybe everyone needs to calm
down because this is just the cyclical
nature of politics and perhaps it was
just the weed talking
but d do you really feel that way that
even now as you see what i think
and and if you take a different position
it's fine sure an administration that's
sort of out of control and now we're
going to expand the courts and all of
this stuff
do you still feel calm within that and
that's a little bit of the the previous
question just related to temperature no
no
i i think it's great and the one thing i
want to point out is you know of course
in california smoking weed is legal
which is something that it was you know
obviously was going to happen when i
started at reason in 1993 and there was
the first medical marijuana vote a
ballot initiative in california in 96
which won overwhelmingly um you know you
knew
legal weed was going to come but it's
kind of amazing that it came
you know and it's it's in a a majority
of people in america live in states
where recreational weed
is legal um you know the drug war is
ending
and it's kind of phenomenal so it's you
know and that's like one of the
libertarians don't have a lot of wins
but this is something
the first issue of reason in 1968 you
know talked about ending the drug war
before richard nixon had even escalated
it in the very early 70s so
you know it's it's kind of good to step
back every once in a while and say like
you know what like
there's a lot of terrible stuff going on
but you know in many ways things are
pretty good
to your larger point i think what we've
specifically
we're talking about in a fictional
universe in that completely fictional
universe absolutely you know it takes
place on the other side of earth
you know in negative earth or something
counter earth um the food was delicious
though at that
uh i seem to remember
looking at that and thinking wow in a
fictional universe i wish i could eat
that food in my
actual place no but um you know it had
more to do with things about free speech
and where we were going because i had
written before
the election uh and this is something i
voted for joe jorgensen i
almost never vote i actually i've only
voted for a major party candidate once
in any election at any level that was
walter mondale in 1984.
um i don't know what i was doing it did
not go well i yeah
now and you know and it's like i i think
what i liked about him was that he
said he was going to raise taxes to
close the deficit i was like okay that's
honest it's suicide but it's honest
but in any case um i had written before
the election here
here are 11 trillion reasons to be
scared shitless about joe biden becoming
president because he had
offered 11 trillion dollars in new
spending
um you know in his campaign platform and
that's really bad because
donald trump had actually met or under
donald trump
the budget had already massively
increased from when he took office
obama things ratcheted up from you know
2009 his first budget year to him
leaving
bush you know had increased spending 50
we have to stop
spending so much money especially since
we're not paying for it
so i i'm not a fan of of joe biden i do
think that we still live in a world of
free speech i dislike very much the way
um you know the social media platforms
the facebooks twitter
youtubes of the world are clamping down
on speech i think that's inarguable and
we have to scream bloody murder
and also build alternatives to that
let's talk about that in a second
yeah you're specifically i think joe
biden
is delivering on exactly what he
promised and that is a
dark winter for america on every level
um you know he and and to this point
like i was just reading today
kamala harris has actually said oh you
know biden
is so busy doing other things he's not
even going to get around to
legalizing or descheduling marijuana at
the federal level
which is also something that was kind of
promised you know so it's like
yeah he's going to be spending tons of
money i mean we we are
busting the budget in a way that is
unimaginable
we can't pay for it bills come due every
dollar the government spends is
one more like it's a deeper finger in
your pocket
that is squeezing you in places you
shouldn't be squeezed it all comes back
to bite us
and joe biden is out of control in that
sense so do you think though the
inherent
problem with this when you when you talk
about 11 trillion in spending or 2.2
incredible good relief or any of this
that the numbers are
so bananas they're so out of control and
it makes sense to nobody
we also know that the you know the
budgets come in and these papers that
look like this and nobody reads them and
all that stuff
but that it it simply is just not sexy
enough
like you could sit here and explain
perfectly why we can't keep
you know doing this and that eventually
we're gonna have to go to war because
we're in a mafia game
basically when if you can't pay which we
obviously can't pay well then you better
have a bigger gun than the other guy
and china might call in the debt one day
but it just isn't sexy enough
i think that that's a real issue and
again you know i'm i'm kind of like
in the persuasion game like i i know
what i believe so i don't feel a need to
express myself with
uh you know like and say i am the true
scotsman i'm the true libertarian and
don't disagree with me otherwise you're
not real or anything like that what i'm
trying to do
is persuade people to have a different
view of the world one in which
individual
and uh you know involuntary individual
freedom and voluntary association
is at the center of everything rather
than kind of top-down coercive
controls of business of culture of life
um and yeah that's a real question and i
think one of the things that i'm trying
to talk about now more
in all of this spending is that you know
it's like
you know when when you're getting all of
your money
from one guy or from you know one source
and it's in you know the capital
district i mean we're in the hunger
games here
you know where everything is being
funneled in from the you know the
provinces of the capital
and then they spit some of it back at
you that comes with a huge amount of
strings attached
and it gets complicated and you know and
it's just
freaking annoying and you know and
especially coming on the heels of the
pandemic
in california in new york the the two
states where i've spent
most of the lockdown you know you have
two
mad men who were being hailed as you
know the great saviors of humanity
by the media by people you know by
politicians and their handlers and all
of that kind of stuff
gavin newsom and andrew coma have been
revealed to be terrible at what they do
and one of them is a truly awful human
being which was hiding in plain sight
wait which one which one uh well you
know what i'll let your
i'll let your our listeners uh decide i
think i know which one you're talking
about i'm honestly
not sure we don't have to choose they
can both be awful human beings as well
as awful uh leaders
um but you know what we're witnessing
now
is a historic moment that i think builds
on two decades of the government at all
levels trying to get bigger certainly
the federal government where
it's spending more money it's regulating
more things uh you know where
we go from a place where you know we
started the 21st century
not having to um you know like
you know not having to take our clothes
off when we go to the airport
you know and and now we are not only
doing that we're talking about seriously
discussing
having to show medical papers in order
to get on a freaking airplane
um you know this is serious stuff and
this is the ground upon which
i think we need to persuade people to
say you know you might want that 1400
check you might want 3 600 to have a kid
and by the way i just want to say it is
so immoral
to have the government trying to dictate
you know how many times you [ __ ] or how
many kids you have
by offering you more and more money and
it's it's also unfair to people who
don't want kids
you know um but having said any of that
like what we need to persuade people
about or what i'm trying to do
is like the more money you get from a
place the more they own you
on some level and what i want is you
know i'm not an anarchist i don't think
there should be no government
um i think there should be a strictly
limited government and a lot of what it
should do
apart from like general defense is you
know it should be helping people who are
poor
or for whatever reason don't have the
resources to fully
um uh you know kind of engage or
participate in society
give give poor people a lot of money to
go to education
to figure out how to live their lives
and things like that but leave middle
class and upper middle class and rich
people
you know we can pay our own way um but
you know we now have a government that
is promising to be all things to all
people
and that you know that paycheck you know
that paycheck from the government
doesn't come free if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell